another way to support the work that we
do is if you ever shop on amazon.com the
shopping you do can support us if before
shopping you visit david pakman.com
slash amazon now here's something
interesting we don't get any personal
info about who buys through our amazon
link we just get a list of items each
day of stuff that was purchased and in
the last week a bunch of samsung galaxy
note 7 accessories were purchased which
is indus interesting because samsung has
taken the galaxy note 7 off the market i
saw videos of this thing spontaneously
catching fire there's an unbelievable
video of a table inside of a fast food
restaurant or know if you've seen this
pad and there's a samsung galaxy note 7
sitting on the table and it's just
smoking i mean it's just it's it's
spontaneously catching fire and a
kitchen employee comes over with kitchen
mitts that are probably used when you're
deep frying fries at a mcdonald's or
something and they pick up the note 7
and it's smoking I mean it's just black
smoke and they toss it outside I was
recently on this flight to Vegas and
they now make an announcement put your
seatbelt on when we tell you to turn off
your phone turn it off
laptops are allowed above 10,000 feet
and Samsung Galaxy Note sevens are not
allowed on the plane a period it's the
first time I've ever seen a specific
device not allowed disaster for Samsung
well yeah at the restaurant I bet it
looked like they were serving fajitas or
something yeah this really couldn't have
happened at a worse time because now
Google's coming out with their pixel
product I mean this has cost them about
10 billion dollars so far and I am a
Tsang Samsung Galaxy 7 user I absolutely
loved the phone it's fantastic it's
terrific I'm finally winning again with
this thing believe me trust me it's
fantastic but the Galaxy Note 7 not good
so I mean I'm wondering who in our
audience is ordering accessories for
their note 7 when you're not even really
supposed to have it anymore because it
could catch fire at any time yeah it's
probably pretty cheap right now imagine
good time to pick up accessories I guess
alright remember if you ever shop on
amazon david pakman.com slash amazon
will redirect you and send us about a 7
or 8 percent kickback from everything
you buy